within 24 hours the community would be
completely destroyed at the hands of
thousands of white riders
it was a massacre a century on and a
president grappling with today's racial
tensions in america
traveled to tulsa to confront the past
being told the horrific detail
of one of the darkest but largely
overlooked moments
in this country's history he came to
remember those who died but also to
promise change
saying the battle for racial equality in
america is far from over
for much too long the history of what
took place here was told
in silence cloaked in darkness
but just because history is silent it
doesn't mean that it did not take
place and while darkness can hide much
it erases nothing it erases nothing
greenwood known as black wall street was
a prosperous african-american community
a century ago
where on the night of may the 31st white
rioters gunned down residents
and set fire to homes block by block
after a black man was accused of
assaulting a white girl
an estimated 300 people were killed and
thousands left homeless
leslie benningfield was a child of six
that night
the memories for her are still vivid but
painful to recall
the soldiers were coming in to run the
rebels out
and uh everybody was running and hiding
and trying to get away i don't know
it's just it's just a big mess only now
are many discovering what happened in
this part of the usa a century ago
and demands are being made for
reparations for greenwood
the events of that night were long
suppressed were not taught in schools
and even those who lived through the
horror found it hard to speak about
the truth of it truly needs to come out
so that real healing can happen
so that there are so many that are still
bound to that incident
and what it meant and what it took away
that they can't move on into what they
can
have and create part of that healing may
come for some families if they're
finally able to lay their ancestors to
rest
mass graves from the massacre are being
excavated in the hope of identifying the
bodies
this taking place a century after so
many died
and at a time of racial reckoning in
america
michelle clifford sky news washington